FEMALE SPEAKER:
For over 20 years,
Duggan McDonnell has been making
his mark on the West Coast
beverage scene, distinguishing
himself at such San Francisco
gems as the Redwood
Room and Absinthe.
He is the founder
and owner of Cantina
and has designed cocktails
for the Sundance Film
Festival, Aspen Food
and Wine, the Omni
Hotel, and many others.
He is also a winemaker
and distiller
and lectures at the Culinary
Institute of America.
Passionate about writing,
as well as mixology,
he has authored
articles and recently
published his first book.
"Drinking the Devil's
Acre-- a Love Letter
from San Francisco
and Her Cocktails"
is at once a bold primer
on modern mixology,
a barman's memoir, and a
dive into San Francisco's
rich cocktail history.
Please join me in
welcoming Duggan McDonnell.
[APPLAUSE]
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Thank you,
[? Marin. ?] [? Marin ?] told
me that she was a really
great Google stalker.
And wonderful bio, thank you.
What's that?
I'm looking off.
Where are you?
How many folks in this
room like to drink?
Cocktails, yeah?
Show of two hands,
perhaps, that.
How many of you in this room
think that you, perhaps,
have a good pallet or at
least an inquisitive one?
You like to go out.
You like to learn.
You like to taste new things.
OK.
I'm that guy, as well.
I found at a very
early age-- and I
was sharing with [? Marin ?]
earlier-- that two decades ago,
during my first summer abroad,
which was when I was 18,
I spent it between high
school and summer in Europe.
You can drink legally there.
And I learned a lot
about myself that summer.
And one of the
things that I learned
is that I was most concerned
about flavor and texture
and not just the buzz
that I was getting
from that pint of Guinness.
And it led me down
a path, or shall
we say a rabbit hole, which
I'm in these two decades later.
This book that's right here,
"Drinking the Devil's Acre,"
is many things.
In addition to narrative,
memoir, and history,
it's also part
cultural anthropology.
And one of the things that
I was most interested in
is studying this
community, thinking
about San Francisco as the
epicenter of the Bay Area,
of the culture of
Northern California,
and how the culture
of California
has historically been
connected to cocktails.
And what I learned was that
it was also historically
connected to how we taste, OK?
In this book, I
make an assertion
that we actually
learn to taste first.
And our palates became developed
first via the cocktail,
all right?
So again, I'm Duggan McDonnell.
And a few months ago, this book,
"Drinking the Devil's Acre,"
was published.
It's history.
It's memoir.
And it tells all of these
years of my time shaking,
and then drinking, behind
the stick, as well.
What I'm most passionate
about, as I said,
is how San Franciscans drank
and came to understand flavor.
And what I'd love to
hear from you today
is whether you agree with
me and whether you've also
experienced this.
The title of this talk is
Bright, Bitter, and Boozy.
Perhaps some of you in this
room can relate to at least one
of those three adjectives.
Whether you're native to the
Bay Area or a recent emigre who
happens to chug
many a cocktail, I
believe that's what we all are.
So here in Northern
California, I'm
here to tell you that your
culture-- our culture--
first experienced
flavor via cocktails.
Our palates found enlightenment
by sipping, not chewing.
Again, the culture
of the Bay Area
first acquired its understanding
and its passion for flavor
through the cocktail glass,
not via fork and plate.
I'm going to read just a
few lines from this book
so that you understand.
"San Francisco began
as a city of drink.
And from its infancy, discerning
and decisive San Franciscans
tippled by calling out
the name of their drink.
The city did not begin with
that ribald Barbary Coast,
nor was it the Arizona or the
Colorado of the Wild West,
where thirsty pioneers
dumbly hollered 'whisky.'
No, no, no.
This was the San Francisco of
the Gold Rush, the Comstock
Lode, a city shaped by the 'Big
Four' and other robber barons.
The prevailing culture spoke
civilly to, rather than shouted
at, the barkeep, 'whisky smash,
if you please, cherry cobbler,
if you don't mind,
claret and lemonade,
if it's no trouble.' It
wasn't a culture that barked
for straight hooch.
Instead, the tune
sung throughout
was of freshly squeezed
citrus, sprigs of peppermint,
dashes of bitters
here and there."
So come along with me and think.
Cocktails offer an
explosion of flavor.
They're liquid combinations
of wine and spirit,
liqueur, fresh produce,
dashes of bitters, tinctures.
And most of these
ingredients are shelf stable.
They can travel across the
world in the hull of a ship,
ready to be blended by
the ounce behind the bar
when they are finally chosen
by their destined barkeep.
Let's remember this old
cocktail called the Martinez.
An Abrahamic cocktail, the
forerunner to the martini,
it tastes of clove, juniper,
cinnamon, orange peel,
tart cherry, vanilla, sassafras,
bitter orange, cardamom.
Rare is that rare
steak that could offer
such an abundance of flavor.
But this cocktail can.
San Francisco, because it has
been bright, bitter, and boozy
from its first week as a city
known round the world in 1849,
has had at the core of its
identity this burst of flavor.
The fastest-growing,
richest city
in the history of the
world got to drink
what it wanted to drink.
And then, San
Francisco got spoiled.
We got used to good drink.
Does that sound familiar, folks?
The richest city in the
history of the world?
What is this Bay Area now?
We have a few bucks
going around, don't we?
And isn't there a
cocktail Renaissance
that's been happening,
as well, simultaneously?
It's an interesting
phenomenon, isn't it?
150ish years ago, San
Francisco had a lot of options,
principally, a large
menu from which to drink.
Then, as now, the
city was a port city.
And it was the port that
fed the city in ideas,
in human populations,
and in drink.
Into this port came the
largest, most diverse stream
of champagne, port, Jamaican
rum, Scotch whisky, Dutch gin,
Bourdeaux, Pisco from
Peru, just to name a few.
Never before had such a
collection of wine and spirits
ever been on offer.
Never before had a city sprung
up, seemingly overnight,
from mountains of
harvested gold.
And again, it was because
of all that gold--
that great disposable income--
that San Francisco commanded
the world's finest drink.
Does that sound like
some of the back bars
that you go and see
in the city today,
where there's 400 bottles
lining the shelves,
and the bar keep
gets to play with all
of these different flavors?
That was happening in the 1850s.
And so imagine
that old bar keep.
Let's think, huh?
Mustache, oil cloth, OK?
You're just here.
Perhaps it's your first job.
And you're standing in front
of all of the splendor.
And you think, what am I going
to do with all this stuff?
Huh?
What would you do?
You'd start mixing,
wouldn't you?
I think I'd feel at home.
And I would've started mixing,
just as I have done recently.
You see, from its birth,
again, San Francisco
has been a city of innovation.
And "Drinking the
Devil's Acre" reveals
that much of that
early innovation
actually happened in the saloon.
The great spirits of the world
captivated the imagination
of the first generation
of mixologists.
And to work they went.
And for that, I'm
quite thankful.
By the time 1881 arrived and
California's first cookbook
was finally published, no less
than the world's first four
cocktail books had come from
the city's finest bar keeps.
Newspapers were full of
advertisements for apothecaries
for homemade bitters.
And I should share with you,
the first piece of fiction
ever published in
California was called "Punch
Drinking and Its Effects."
First piece of fiction
published in our state
was about a cocktail.
The local landscape was
lousy with breweries,
lousy with local distilleries.
Then came the wineries.
And then finally
into full bloom came
the drinking culture of Northern
California, the most prolific
and the greatest contributor
of intellectual property
to drink the world
will ever know.
This is something
that I'm proud of.
This is something,
frankly, that makes
our lives a lot more delicious.
Close your eyes with me.
The Gold Rush, the Comstock
Lode, the whaling years,
railroad barons.
The Martinez, the whisky
smash, the gin fizz, punches,
sours, and flips.
IBM, Apple, YouTube.
The Mai Tai, the lemon
drop, Pisco punch.
Friendster, Facebook.
The chartreuse swizzle,
the basil gimlet, Google,
and the Irish coffee-- all
of these, local innovations,
the greatest diversity of
liquid decadence the world
has ever known.
And together, money and
cocktails shall ever flow.
Now let's return to why San
Francisco learned specifically
about flavor from drink.
Produce is perishable, yes?
Requiring preservation
for travel.
Not so, a barrel of rum
or a bottle of sherry.
Meats and vegetables today
benefit from refrigerated box
cars, trucks perfectly
chilled, much of it
frozen, right, while
traveling America's highways.
Now California cuisine could not
and did not develop to anything
like it is today until long
after electric generators were
developed, mass produced,
until highways were chock full
with trucks traveling from
farm to city every single day.
It's a very recent phenomenon.
Our palates were first
informed by drink.
And in California, it is a
bright, bitter, and boozy
pallet we have.
So what do I mean by bright?
Does it have an IQ?
[LAUGHS]
Is it merely something, say,
citric-- a little fresh lemon
in your water or
in your martini?
It can be, as citrus
was first cultivated
in the United States
by the Spanish fathers
here, in early California.
But without balance-- a
little sugar-- citric really
just means acidic, which can
be too tart, which can be,
frankly, yuck, all right?
So I mean that cocktails
in Northern California
are abundant with citrus,
whether for its juice
to be squeezed or for
essential oils found
in the skins of
lemons and oranges
to be expressed over, into
Negronis, Old Fashioneds.
And I do not mean citrus
come from Florida.
What do I mean?
Local satsumas,
local Meyer lemons
because that is
what prevails here.
Because when produce is fresh,
the height of its flavor
experience is, in fact, higher.
By bright, I also
mean herbaceous.
What was the name of
the little Spanish town
at the end of the
mythic peninsula
before it became known
as San Francisco?
Does anybody know?
AUDIENCE: Yerba Buena?
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Yerba Buena,
says the gentleman in row two.
Right.
And that means "good herb," as
it was called by the Spanish,
for all the plentiful
wild mint that
was grown all over the land.
Trader Vic, that
native San Franciscan,
who created the Mai
Tai, the Scorpion Bowl,
amongst many other wildly
imaginative offerings--
his favorite garnish of
choice was a mint sprig--
smacking it-- something bright,
something to sort of heighten
that aromatic
experience of cocktails.
And in the mid '90s, long
before the mojito craze
swept the country,
that lovely high ball,
bright with fresh mint,
was alive and well
in San Francisco.
Let's talk about bitterness.
Has anyone ever
experienced bitterness?
In a cocktail, hmm?
Sure, sure, sure.
Well, San Francisco
has long been bitter.
But it's actually been
a preference of ours.
I mentioned that in
the Gold Rush era,
dozens of brands of local
bitters were being produced.
They were consumed for health--
folk medicine, if you will.
And the ingredients used
were this amazing combination
of local produce, along
with exotic roots and spices
freshly imported from the
Andes or from Canton China.
And as bitters
became ubiquitous,
so too did these San
Francentric combinations
of bitter global flavor.
Fast forward to World War I, OK?
Northern Italy becomes a
front in a vicious fight.
Trench warfare ensues, and the
entire region is destabilized.
Within the next decade,
tens of thousands
of immigrants from
Northern California
came to San Francisco and
settled in the North Beach
region.
With them, they brought their
two local preferred hamaros.
What are the names
of those brands?
Campari, Fernet-Branca, OK?
If you've ever wondered how San
Francisco acquired its passion
for the Negroni cocktail or
for chugging shots of Fernet,
not only does it go
back to North Beach
and that northern
Italian migration
during the '20s,
which was prohibition,
remember, but also before that.
This region has
preferred something
bitter on the pallet
for nearly 150 years.
Let's talk about
being boozy, shall we?
Many of you asked if I'd brought
my samples with me today.
I'm sorry, I did not.
In the old days, the
port of San Francisco,
and today, the Port of Oakland,
receives more coffee beans
than any other
port in the world.
Does anyone know that?
Why am I talking about coffee?
Stay tuned.
Long ago, it was
Hills Brothers, which
was located on the
waterfront, that dominated
the national coffee landscape.
Today, a few different
companies, but locally, we
have artisanal brands--
Blue Bottle, Equator.
But now, let's remember the
most widely known coffee
drink all over the world,
which comes from San Francisco,
has what in it?
A slug of whisky-- the
Irish coffee, folks.
One of the drinks that San
Francisco is most famed for,
its most famous coffee drink,
actually has booze in it,
and quite a bit of it.
Has anyone here been
to the Buena Vista?
Full house, perfect. [LAUGHS]
I'm a local, and I go often.
Northern California,
with its breweries,
wineries, and distilleries
produces the largest amount
of alcohol in the country.
That should come as no surprise.
California as a state
also imports and consumes
the largest amount of
alcohol in the nation.
It is boozy to its core.
And so I wonder, folks, with all
this alcohol, these experiences
of bright, of bitter, and boozy,
I wonder if we think better.
I wonder if we perform better.
I wonder if we
work harder because
of that delicious, abundant
reward of great drink
all around us.
I think that there's
a connection.
I wonder how intrinsically
linked cocktails just
might be to the world's
great culinary region,
to the center of innovation.
I'll leave you with a quote
from Doris Muscatine's epic
book, "Old San Francisco,"
which I quote in my book.
And it's one of my favorites.
And I think it describes
San Francisco, then and now,
perfectly.
She says, "Drinking was
such a fact of city life
that it was certainly
considered no disgrace
to frequent a saloon, which
the entire populace did
without embarrassment.
Since everybody acknowledged
that everybody drank,
large-scale social drinking
became taken for granted.
And there was consequently
little stigma attached.
San Francisco has never lost
its enthusiasm for alcohol."
Thank you for your time.
And now I'd like to hear from
you what your thoughts are
on being bright,
bitter, and boozy,
some of your favorite
watering holes,
cocktails to make or shake.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I'm going
to boozy and bitter.
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it true
that Anchor Brewery sort of
invented the modern IPA?
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: I would say
that would be our fine friends
up in Chico.
AUDIENCE: In Chico.
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Sierra Nevada.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: But one of
the things that Anchor did
was revive the rye
whisky revolution.
I have the year in the book.
But I think it was,
perhaps, it was '97 or '99.
And Anchor became the first and
only distillery in the United
States to make 100% rye whisky.
And that wasn't
happening anywhere.
Well, here we are,
again, San Francisco
long ahead of the curve.
And we're in the midst of not
only a whisky revolution right
now but a rye revolution.
The old fashioned is one of
the most popular cocktails
in the country.
Whisky has outpaced
vodka in recent sales.
And it all goes back, I
think, to the late '90s,
when Fritz Maytag,
the previous owner,
said I'm going to do this.
It's time that America
sort of take back
it's rye whisky heritage.
And in fact, long before,
say, there were vines
planted throughout
Northern California,
it was actually fields of rye.
So it was a local thing.
So the distilleries
that were happening here
in the 1860s and '70s produce a
ton of specifically rye whisky.
That was his inheritance.
That's our inheritance.
So I'm glad he did it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
touching on the connection
between wealth and drinking.
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Mm-hm.
AUDIENCE: What is
the best cocktail
for coping with gentrification?
[LAUGHTER]
DUGGAN MCDONNELL:
Ah, that is the best
question that I've been asked
this fall on this book tour.
Thank you for asking that.
Something expensive, I
think, is the right answer.
Did everybody hear the question?
The best cocktail to drink while
coping with gentrification.
I'm going to steal that.
Yes, something
expensive and something
on someone else's tab, I think,
is the right way to do it.
Do you have a preference?
AUDIENCE: I had something, I
think, last week or the week
before.
And it was over by Civic Center.
And it was whisky in a stout,
along with nutmeg and cinnamon.
And I just loved it.
I had another.
DUGGAN MCDONNELL:
Hits you right there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DUGGAN MCDONNELL:
So you had two.
That's great.
Did you pay for them?
What a good man.
Well--
[LAUGHTER]
You put it on a
credit card, though.
You'll deal with it at
the end of the month.
All right.
Sure.
The question is, can I name
a few local rye whiskys.
So in addition to
Anchor, the folks
over at St. George Spirits
are getting into the whisky
business, not just rye yet,
but they're working on that.
But there is a
distillery up in Sonoma
by the name of--
folks, what is it?
Spirit Works?
AUDIENCE: Spirit Works.
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Yeah,
they also make the sloe gin.
They are just about to
launch a straight rye whisky.
And I tasted it last week.
It's very nice.
AUDIENCE: So are they local?
Are they actual
local distilleries?
They are distillering
their own alcohol?
DUGGAN MCDONNELL:
So yeah, they are
what you would call part of
the grain-to-glass movement.
Where the question
is coming from
is that the great majority
of whisky in this country
is actually made
by very few people.
There's a couple distilleries
in the middle of the country
that everyone just buys
from and then re-distills
or does their own thing.
Or they say, hey,
this is our recipe.
You guys make it,
and give it to us.
And then we'll finish it, or
we'll barrel it or something.
Some part of that
process is largely
what's happening in the country.
There are certain folks, like
Buffalo Trace, Wild Turkey,
they do everything on their own.
But for instance,
there are brands
that are largely outsourced.
The local guys now
are trying to be
more a part of this
California ethos, which
is the grain-to-glass movement.
And I think we're going
to see more of that,
not just here but
throughout the country.
AUDIENCE: More of the--
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: More of
the grain-to-glass movement--
basically, controlling the
ingredients and all the steps
to ensure quality and
also to be able to connect
with your consumer to
say, look, we made this.
And here's why.
And you can answer
every single question
because your steps are
vertically integrated.
You know exactly how
everything's been made.
AUDIENCE: You also
mentioned some
herbs coming from the Andes?
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Mm-hm.
AUDIENCE: For instance what?
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Sure, well,
coca leaves used to be legal.
But quinine, [INAUDIBLE]
cinchona bark,
is the main one that did and
does still come from Peru.
Quinine is the principal
ingredient in what?
Anyone know?
AUDIENCE: Tonic.
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Tonic, mm-hm.
So not just in tonic
water, but before that,
it was in many different
formulas for bitters.
And there's other things coming
from down there, as well.
So and of course, San Francisco
being on the Pacific, stuff
would stop off in
those ports down here.
They'd load it on.
They'd do some commerce.
Come up here to the
Port of San Francisco--
another layer of commerce.
And then folks would take
them to their "pharmacies"
and have at it.
AUDIENCE: So what are some of
your favorite San Francisco
establishments for new and
inventive cocktails these days?
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: OK.
So this book, "Drinking
the Devil's Acre,"
was organized according
to 25 chapters, OK?
25 cocktails that are
iconic and celebrated
in San Francisco, whether
created there or sacred to.
Within those 25 chapters,
I provide some spots.
One of them is, of
course, the Irish coffee
in the Buena Vista.
So that's one.
Comstock Saloon is another.
You've probably heard about
Trick Dog in The Mission.
It's getting a lot of ink.
That's a great one.
I was just recommending
Benjamin Cooper,
which is a lovely
little hidden gem
on a mid-level mezzanine in a
hotel right off Union Square.
No signage, no nothing.
Really great.
Just opened up.
Whitechapel is this stunning
new gin bar in the Tenderloin.
You walk right in,
and you feel like you
are in, like, a Terry Gilliam
film-- "Brazil," "12 Monkeys."
It's this wild
pseudo-London interior.
Whitechapel-- I
recommend it, yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Hmm, I'll try that.
Yeah, I also just recently
discovered Alembic.
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Of course.
Yeah, that's a staple.
That's a staple.
I think that opened up in 2006,
same time as my bar, Cantina,
opened.
They opened just a few
months before my place.
AUDIENCE: So from the food
side, I think generally,
people have talked about
how American pallets have
become much sweeter, saltier.
How do you think
that our palates have
evolved on the alcohol side?
And are there any flavors
you think that we've
lost that we should rediscover?
DUGGAN MCDONNELL:
Hmm, great question.
Thank you for asking.
So I think that here
in California, we
began with a bright, bitter, and
boozy palate, and we lost it.
And I think that we're actually
in the process of gaining it
back.
I think that the middle
20th century screwed us up.
On the food side, everything
was available in a can, right?
Or it was frozen or
something like that.
And that became true,
not just in food,
by having cans of beans
and meats and vegetables,
but also with cocktails, right?
All of a sudden,
everything came in a mix.
And it was some funny color
so, like, the guys in space
could just grab a
bunch of bottles
and go have a cocktail party.
They didn't know there
was a farm anywhere.
And that went on for decades.
And recently, call it
the whole-foods movement
or some sort of farmers
market, farm-to-glass movement,
if you will-- we're
starting to get this back.
Anytime you put
anything fresh in there,
it's going to be brighter.
But it's also going to sway.
So because that flavor
is alive, right,
and it's changing in your glass.
So we're starting to
see cocktails that
have to be made with precision.
So we're getting better
in our recipes, all right.
Because we have better
access to ingredients, now
and also, thankfully
to the internet,
we have this access
to information
like we've never had before.
It used to be you had
to publish a book.
And people had to buy a
book to get great stories
and great recipes.
That's not true anymore.
You can find a lot of
information on the internet.
And so now, if you
go to your BevMo!
and your Whole Foods and
you have a smartphone,
you can make amazing cocktails.
And that's the
era that we're in.
And so I think we're
regaining that.
I think it's so wild that
kale and arugula is popular.
But then you might think
that it's also wild
that homemade bitters
and tinctures from bell
peppers and many other things
are also just as popular.
And I think all of that is
informing our palate, so
on the plate and in the glass.
That's where we're at right now.
And I think it's only going to
continue because of this access
that we have.
And I can't imagine going
back into the dark ages
of a couple decades ago.
I grew up thinking that most
green beans came from a can.
How about you?
AUDIENCE: I grew up in
California, so not so much.
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: I
grew up in Santa Clara,
OK, the next county down.
And we had a garden, but a
garden yields, what, couple
of meals worth?
Most of the green beans had
a Jolly Green Giant on them.
And there was
commercials about him.
He was my friend.
And that was my
experience with food.
And I think we're never
going to go back there.
I hope, at least.
AUDIENCE: How do
you start creating?
And what's your approach
to creating a new cocktail?
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Hmm.
So how do I create
new cocktails?
Quite honestly, because I've
been thinking about alcohol
and flavor for
over two decades, I
have a big bank between
the small space in my ears.
It's all taken up with
boozy flavors and ideas.
And so even if I taste something
new for the first time,
I can then associate it with
hundreds of other things.
And the ideas
mostly come quickly.
And I don't even
need to make them.
I know what it's going to taste
like ahead of time because I
do all of the balance
in my head and I know
the structures and all that.
I'm constantly doing
development like that.
And it's sort of like composing.
I can create the theory
in my head first.
And then I can make it.
Yeah, that kind of stacks
up to exactly how I thought.
And I might adjust it by a
quarter or a half ounce, one
thing or the other,
and it's done.
But again, that's only come
from decades of drinking
and thinking about drink.
One of the things that I do,
though, when I'm training.
And one of the things that
I make all of my staff
do, and it's the second or third
to last chapter in this book,
is I talk about the most
important tool behind any bar.
Can anyone think
about what that is?
Is it a shaker?
Is it a muddler?
Anyone know?
It's a straw, OK?
It's the tasting straw.
And I grab it like this.
And I go like this.
And I pop it in, and I taste.
And every single time I'm making
a cocktail-- you're my guests,
you're at my bar, you order
a margarita or a manhattan.
It's the same recipe
I've made 10,000 times.
But I dip and I taste
just to make sure.
I'm not looking to get drunk.
That 16th of an ounce is not
going to hurt me in any way.
But what I'm doing
is always affirming.
But I'm also-- it's
quality control there.
I'm making sure that
something isn't off,
that the vermouth
hasn't gone bad
or that perhaps the lime
was too sour, too acidic,
and I need to adjust.
Or perhaps I didn't
shake it as long,
so there's not enough dilution.
Or enough air
didn't get in there
to open up the flavors--
all of those things.
So not only have I just
tasted all the bottles
and tasted a lime
or a pineapple,
but I've tasted these
combinations hundreds
of thousands of times.
And so I understand
the relationships.
And that's what I would
advocate is to always
be tasting and thinking.
Have that cognizance.
AUDIENCE: I have one
more if nobody-- [LAUGHS]
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Hit me.
AUDIENCE: So on the,
again, going back to,
like, the food movements,
away from sugar in general,
but particularly
refined sugar, do
you see a trend going
that same direction?
Because sugar's a very
essential component
of cocktails and balance.
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Hmm.
So talking about
sweeteners, I think
that we've almost lost corn
syrup in the bar world.
There are certainly-- there's
mixers that still use it.
But those mixers have just
been downgraded so much
that no one's interested.
We also know how to
make syrups on our own
now-- it's easy-- with
fruit and sugar and water.
So there's that.
There's also 100% cane
movement that's going on.
And then there's many different
types of cane out there
and processed cane, whether
you're talking about Turbinado
or finding molasses
or using unbleached.
There's many different
things out there.
And then you have alternate
sugar sources, right.
Within the last
dozen years, we've
seen an explosion
of agave nectar,
right, as a sweetener,
which does not give you
much of a glycemic hit, sort
of more of a steady drip
into your system, which also
provides a nice sweetening
viscosity in cocktails.
Specifically, it's
popular now in margaritas,
almost changing that
classic margarita recipe
from tequila,
lime, and Cointreau
to tequila, lime,
and agave nectar.
And that's pretty much the San
Francisco margarita now-- very
healthy and a lighter style.
And then, of course,
we've got honey.
Folks are-- cocktail bars
now across the country
are lousy with honey.
And I think that's
a great thing.
You make a honey syrup, and
then you employ that in.
And again, different
sweeteners are coming about.
Does that answer your question?
I think that's both
healthier, and it's also
expanding flavor
possibilities, both of which
I think are important.
AUDIENCE: So I guess
about a year ago I,
for the first time, moved
into an apartment that
actually has room for a bar.
So I've--
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Good for you.
AUDIENCE: --been developing a--
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: You've
got your priorities right.
AUDIENCE: I got my
priorities right, yeah.
So for the first time,
now I have sort of a bar.
And I've got 20 to 30
bottles or something.
But I'm wondering,
how do you look
about developing a home bar?
What are the things that
you look for to expand it
or the tools that you want or--
DUGGAN MCDONNELL:
Great question--
expanding the home bar.
What an important thing, right?
There's books out there.
I think there's one
that just came out
called "The 12 Bottle Bar."
So perhaps buy that one.
There's a lot of blogs
out there on that.
But essentially, I
think you probably
need to have one of each of
the major spirit categories
out there.
But finding that bottle can
be a difficult thing, OK.
And, say, when you're
judging your vodka,
don't judge it by cracking
it, pouring it neat,
lukewarm in the glass, and
then drinking it like that
because that's never
how you're going
to drink your vodka, right?
So you want to
basically road test it.
And that's one of
the things that I
share in the book is that
there wasn't one gin or whisky
or vodka or even
tequila, et cetera,
that I was always
entirely satisfied.
You would reach for
one gin for a Negroni.
And then you'd reach for another
one for, say, an Aviation.
What I started doing
is creating blends.
So as I have all of these
different opportunities
in-- because that's
what I call the bottles.
I call them
opportunities behind me.
I said, OK, I'm going
to bring them together.
So then I would create
these master blends
that I would keep
in the speed well
at the bar that would have four
different types of gin in it.
And then I would have this
master cocktail spirit
based upon these blends
and my years of experience
of blending.
And then, aha, every gin drink
that I ever made was awesome.
So if you want to do that,
like, if you're a gin nerd,
then buy the four
bottle that I prescribe.
And make the blends, and see
if all of your gin cocktails
turn out perfect.
AUDIENCE: How would
you characterize
the art of bartending
in this country today?
DUGGAN MCDONNELL: Wow, the
art of bartending today.
I'm going to actually say that
the art has started to slip.
And it's actually
going into a realm
where it's just
craft and discipline.
And I think that that's OK.
I think that we got
overwhelmed with art.
And now there's so many
options-- so many bottles,
as I've been talking
about, so many things
that my concern, Mike, in how
I'm answering this question
is that I hope that
mixologists are not
staring into their
navels, more concerned
by the three different
types of bitters that
are going into the
cocktails and the hand
carving of an ice
for an old fashioned
or where their local
Meyer lemons are
sourced because that's
really not what it's about.
I think that cocktails
should be artfully made.
But ultimately, I still
hope that people go to bars
to get laid and to
have a great time
and to forget and to
cope with gentrification
and to wake up with a hangover
in the morning and be proud.
And I hope that this
cocktail Renaissance does not
screw all that up for us because
cocktails should, frankly,
still equal a great time.
And so in spite of
all my pontificating
and my seriousness about
where our palates come
from in this community in
this part of the world,
I still believe that,
frankly, a cocktail
needs to be a great time.
And hopefully, it'll
be a balanced one.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]